the legendary Nevisole. It combines
together elements of body tracing as
well as hybrids to create something new,
unique, and stunning. Well, kind of new.
This one's been around, I think, for
like a decade and a half. But I was
informed recently that I've never done a
detailed tutorial on it. So, I'm going
to fix that today.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video I am tackling
the theory and practice behind
performing the Neol body tracing hybrid.
But before we dive in, I just want to
give a quick shout out to the friends of
the channel. Big thanks to Dark Monk,
Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys,
Peroter Light Toys, and Ultraoy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible. You can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video. And special thanks to the
non-b businessiness friend of the
channel, Becca Becklanin. Thank you so
very much for supporting my channel, my
work, and my mission. So, in the course
of this tutorial, I'm going to take you
through the basic theory of how this
trick works, the mechanics of how to
perform it, and also some tips on how
you can dance it up if that's your
thing. There are two PO tricks that if
you have them under your belt, it's
going to make your life a lot easier in
getting this trick down. Uh the first of
them, of course, is the crosser. That is
uh this kind of reelbased PO move
wherein we have our arms crossed and
we're spinning the PO in split time,
same direction. In addition, it'll also
be helpful to have down your windmills.
I will go ahead and include links to
tutorials for both tricks down in the
description as well as up in the cards.
Oh, yeah. So, obvious question, why is
it that we call this the Neasol? Well,
the short answer is that there were a
lot of people playing around with these
hybrids back in the day, but the one who
made this hybrid look really good and
popularized it and got a lot of other
people wanting to learn how to do it was
a Swedish PO spinner by the name of
Thomas Johansson, who went by the
nickname Neol. So, there you go. All
right. So, to understand the Neol, we're
going to need three specific pieces
here. We're going to need to understand
how the timing and direction works.
We're going to need to understand the
two PO patterns that it's made up of,
and we're going to need to understand
the mechanics of how all those pieces
fit together. So, first up, as we're
taking a look at the actual move here, I
want you to note something kind of
interesting about how the PO are moving
and how my hands are moving. If I freeze
the poi at any point, they're spinning
in split time, same direction. Whereas,
if I take the poi out of it, all of a
sudden, you'll notice that my arms are
moving around in a reverse butterfly.
that is my hands are moving around in
together opposite. Uh if you are
unfamiliar with timing and direction, I
will go ahead and include a link to uh a
breakdown of what that is down in the
description as well as up in the cards.
But suffice it to say, we are combining
together these two very different uh
timing and direction modes in order to
make this trick work. And it is
important that you know how to keep
timing and direction consistent with
each of these pieces as we go through
them. The next piece of the puzzle is to
understand which poi patterns are being
put together in this hybrid. Say that 10
times fast. So if we single out just
what my right hand is doing here, you're
going to see that it does a little pedal
behind my left shoulder and then another
little pedal off on my far right side
like so. This means that my right hand
is performing a two-pedal inspin flower
and specifically an in-pin flower where
the pedals are on the horizontals
instead of the verticals. I just happen
to be tucking one of those pedals behind
my shoulder as I take my right hand
around going clockwise. And by the same
token, if we take the right hand out of
the equation now, we can see that my
left hand is performing a four pedal
anti-pin flower. And specifically, it is
performing a box mode version of a four
pedal anti-pin flower. Uh this is the
version where instead of the pedals
being top, side, down, side, they're
instead on the diagonals here. Uh and
interestingly enough, between two of
those pedals, I'm sliding the poi back
behind my head, almost like it's
performing a little pendulum for a
second here. So, if you're paying
attention, that means that both the
right hand and the left hand send the po
behind my body at different points in
the course of this pattern. So, just to
start with, you can actually practice
each of these pieces by themselves. You
can perform that two petedal inspin
flower with your right hand by reaching
under your left armpit to do the first
petal and then over to your right to do
the second petal. Whereas with your left
hand, you can work on doing that four
petal anti-pin flower and taking that
region between the two top petals and
sliding it back behind your head like
so. Now, one thing that is really
important to keep in mind here is that
both of the poi in the way that I'm
teaching this trick are going to be
spinning around clockwise. So, keep that
in mind as you're drilling both of these
tricks. It'll save you a lot of
headaches later on. All right, so with
all that said, let's take a look through
each of the different pieces of this
move so we can get a handle on what
we're trying to get to. The move starts
with our arms spllayed out to either
side, spinning the po split time, same
direction. And it begins when we bring
our hands both down towards our hips and
then cross them. As we perform this
cross, our right hand is reaching under
our left hand and it's performing that
little pedal back behind our left
armpit. As the right hand poi completes
that pedal, it then switches around back
in front of us and we bring our left
hand up to glide the left hand poi
behind our head. We slide the left hand
poi back behind our head and shoulders
as it reaches out to the left. And as it
completes the top left petal of the
anti- spin flower, we swing it back
around in front of us. From here, our
arms return to the position that we
started in, spllayed out to the sides
and spinning the po in split time, same
direction. All right, now let's do a
walkthrough on how we perform this
trick. It's going to start by just
working with our hands. And
specifically, I'm going to bring both of
my arms down and around from the
outsides to cross here in front of me at
shoulder level. Now, please note, I have
my left hand on top of my right hand.
This means that when I flip my arms up,
the left hand goes from being on top to
being behind my head. This is how it
gets into that position. From here, I
then spllay both of my arms straight out
to the sides, and I return to the
position that I started in. So, I draw
them down and around. I cross them at
shoulder level with my left hand high.
And as they continue to push up, that
pushes my left arm behind my head. And
then they can go back out to the sides.
Here's that from the side. I start out
to the sides. I bring my arms down and
around. I cross them at shoulder level
with my left hand on top. And I push the
left hand up behind my head. As my arms
continue outward, I go down, cross, up,
and out. Down, cross, up, and out.
Again, from the front. Down, cross, up,
and out. Down, cross, up, and out. All
right, so let's get the poi involved.
We're going to start with our arms
spllayed out to the sides here. Spinning
the PO split time, same direction. And
as we come down and around, oh goodness,
the poi are going to tangle, right? Not
so fast. Instead, as we go down and
around, the first thing you're going to
want to do is reach that right hand poi
around back behind you. Uh, if you want
to, you can turn a little bit to your
stage left to really get this in place.
And in the process, you'll wind up in a
position that we well know from doing
crossers. We're not going to do a full
crosser here, though. We're only doing
like a section of what we would
recognized as a crosser. From here, we
then push that left hand up just like we
practiced in the hand section. And that
sticks our left hand poi behind our head
like so. Now, this is a position that is
familiar from doing windmills, but for
the fact that we're not switching which
hand is going behind our head. It's
always going to be the left one behind
our head as we're doing this here. So
from here we bring our arms out and
remember that the left hand poi is going
to switch back in front of you after
going through that top left pedal of the
box mode four pedal anti-pin flower. So
al together then I'm bringing my right
hand under and behind my left hand over
and behind and then bringing both out
front out to the sides. So right under
left behind out to the sides. You can do
three beats in each spot if you like. 1
2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 Like so. If you want to
track where each PO is going in front of
and behind you, I can do this from the
side for you. So, we have both in front,
right behind, left behind, both in
front, right behind, left behind, both
in front. And again, you can practice
doing one, two, three, one, two, three,
one, two, three. And then you can work
your way down to doing one, two, one,
two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one,
two, before trying to just go one beat,
one beat, one beat, one beat, one beat,
one beat. In which case, that's the
hybrid right there. I find it's really
helpful to think through the rhythm of
it like this. Right behind, left behind,
out. Right behind, left behind, out.
Right behind, left behind, out as I'm
performing the hybrid. Your mileage may
vary, but just keeping this rhythm in
mind as I'm doing it, I tend to find
really helps me get through it. All
right, so you got a working knowledge of
how to do this hybrid. Now, what are
some things that you can do with it?
What are some ways that you can dance it
up? And what are some transitions that
you can do with it? So, I have two dance
moves that I really, really love doing
with this hybrid. Uh, the first one has
more of a classical or modern dance kind
of flavor to it, and the other one has
more of a hip-hop flavor to it. Here's
both of them. First and foremost, as my
arms are going up, that kind of makes me
want to bring my leg up as well. And
when I bring my arms out, that makes me
want to bring my leg out as well. So
really what's going on with the leg here
is that I'm pulling it up in P and then
kicking it out in a botma as my arms are
going out to the sides uh at the end of
the move. So I draw my knee and arms up
and out. Draw my knee and arms up and
out like so. The other dance move I
really enjoy doing with the Nevisole is
a crisscross from hip hop. Basically it
looks like this. You start with your
feet a shoulders width apart and you do
a little hop and you cross your legs. In
this case, I crossed my right foot over
my left foot. In order to unwind from
this, I'm going to pivot around on the
balls of my feet around to my left. And
as I face upstage, I have uncrossed my
legs. Now I'm going to recross them by
continuing to pivot on the balls of my
feet all the way around to the left. And
then I can step out to reset. So, how
does this work with the Neasol? I'm so
glad you asked. As I'm crossing my arms
and bringing them up, boom. That's when
I do the little leap to cross my legs.
And as I uncross and recross them, I do
a simple extension in split time, same
direction. And then I do a spiral wrap
to finish things off when I step out of
it. So, al together then we go up, out,
around, and finish. Tada. And of course,
as you might have guessed, since the
Neol contains parts that feel very much
like crossers and windmills, there are
easy transitions there to get into both
moves if you so choose. Those aren't the
only options, though. Um, I personally
find that the Neasol is a great place to
get into archer fountains coming off of
the bottom and then going right back
into them. And of course, there's a
whole host of split time, same direction
moves that you can get to from that
position out in the sides where you have
your arm spread out and the PO spinning
in split time same direction. This is an
easy transition point. And if you're
looking for something just a little bit
spicier, here's a really fun anti-brid
transition. As you're coming up through
the middle there, you may notice that
you're in a position where the two poi
are overlapped by a PO's length. When
you get into this spot, you can actually
drop both of the poi down and switch the
orientation of your hands to get into
something like cat eye versus isolation.
Or you could try and get a little bit
more ambitious and switch it into an
actual isolation. To see that in motion,
here's what it looks like.
Pretty cool, huh? All right, so I hope
this helped. Get down those Neol hybrids
out there and go out and do cool things
with them. I can't wait to see it. Be
sure to like, comment, share, and
subscribe to help other people find this
video and to help my channel grow.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I want to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you so much. You
all rock. And if you yourself are
interested in getting your name in the
credits or access to any other of a host
of awesome rewards that I have
available, you can go sign up for my
Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo.
I'll include a link down in the
description as well as up in the cards.
Please help me out in my mission of
bringing po spinning and flow arts to
the whole wide world. Thank you in
advance. And if you'd like to learn more
about poi hybrids and all of their
various types and sunundry details, I
did a massive video on this topic
several years ago that I'll go ahead and
link to down in the description as well
as up on screen. Thanks so much for
watching. Make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon. Take care now. Peace.
[Music]